cette semaine dans les médias il y a un
nom qu'on a beaucoup entendu c'est celui
de zépréguhé goût du fric et on dit
frais qui vous dit derrière ce
pseudonyme se cache en réalité sylvain
hélène à professeurs des écoles atypique
puisqu'il a décidé de se faire tatouer
des pieds à la tête
un style original qui jusque là ne
semblait pas poser particulièrement de
problème sauf que voilà il ya quelques
jours une parents d'élèves s'est plaint
de lui indiquant qu'il faisait peur à sa
fille je trouve cela inapproprié pour
des cp ou des ce1
c'est comme s'ils s'étaient déguisés
pour halloween je suis très surprise que
l'éducation nationale laisse faire ça
considéré comme l'homme le plus tatoué
de france sept instituteurs enseignent
depuis des années et pour lui cela ne
pose aucun problème
je n'ai aucun problème avec les élèves
que j'ai eu au bout de deux minutes tout
va bien ils oublient complètement ce à
quoi je ressemble sur les réseaux
sociaux comme sur les plateaux
les avis sont extrêmement divisé sur le
sujet mais alors pourquoi le professeur
tatoué fait-il autant que les militaires
alors est ce que vous comprenez la
polémique autour oui voilà de sylvain
est ce que vous surtout la question
parce qu elle est pas belle la vie est
ce que vous voulez c'est ce que vous
enverriez vos enfants à l'école avec
sylvain est ce que ça vous dérangerait
oui ou non merci sylvain d'être avec
nous tout cas ce soir
merci d'être là vous alors vous êtes
l'homme le plus titré de france
et depuis quelques mois il ya des
parents qui n'hésitent pas à envoyer des
courriers de menaces à votre hiérarchie
pour vous faire quitter votre poste
aujourd'hui plusieurs parents ont
déclaré ne plus vouloir voir enseigner
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à ses
parents je répondais jacques à chaque
fois ce sont des parents d'élèves que je
n'ai pas en classe d'accord les élèves
que j'ai en classe tout se passe très
très bien très rapidement et à la fin de
l'année tout le monde m'a d'heure on
passe des super moments ensemble et les
parents me remercie c'est à chaque fois
des parents d'enfants que je croise une
fois ou deux dans la cour de récréation
ou dans le couloir
donc c'est tout le temps les gens qui ne
me connaissent pas qu'ils auraient mais
venu me voir et qui m'ont jugé que sur
mon apparence d'accord et les les
parents qui doivent des élèves qui sont
de classe je n'avais jamais eu de
problème prenez jamais de problème en
tout cas sur mon apparence après il ya
des trucs sur alors on a plein de
questions à vous poser
bien entendu je voudrais savoir vous
nathalie marque et non à non moi je mets
mes enfants n'auraient pas de soucis et
vous savez moi j'ai alors ado kwa donc
oui oui pardon que c'est louis accord
donc vous n'aurez pas de soucis aux
non-voyants et absolument pas de souci
est d'ailleurs moi j'ai ma fille quand
je leur parlais de ma fille mais qui
avait une prof d'histoire-géo il ya deux
ans et elle était tirée à quatre
épingles trou tout joli tout ça et
c'était une vraie [ __ ] avec ma fille
également une vraie [ __ ] et c'est une
routine avaient cerné un petit pernaut
j'espère qu'elles montrent pas raison
l'amenant piperno et elle fera qu'assez
tout le temps ma fille est d'ailleurs
julie interdit d'aller en cours
d'histoire géo si je pense que c est une
bonne une bonne leçon de tolérance aussi
qu'il donne monsieur alors sans langue
de bois dit la vérité jradi bref d'être
la seule à dire non alors moi donc
infiniment ce que vous êtes en tant
qu'individu je trouve que d'ailleurs
vous êtes une sorte d'oeuvre d'art
éphémère puisque lorsque vous êtes en
work in progress en plus donc j'aime
bien votre démarche philosophique en
tant que artiste apprend tant que
professeur moi personnellement si ma
fille était donc en petite section va
pas en petite section mais au cp ou par
un pouce et lun j'avais quelques rails
sylvain je suis remplaçant à face à
l'eire qui s'avèreront ça fait 12 ans
que je suis enseignant et ça fait trois
ans que je fais des remplacements courts
d'accord par exemple aujourd'hui avec
des ce2 mais alors il mardi avait des cp
donc cpt et en remplaçant c'est ça un
remplacement donc voir était juste par
exemple deux jours ça dépend mais las
l'année dernière j'ai fait six mois dans
la même école ça dépend vraiment
d'accord alors moi par exemple par
exemple à titre personnel je suis plus
sur le modèle de la troisième république
gémenos le professeur est une sorte de
voile à 2-2 dresscode voilà quelque
chose d'un peu impunis formé quelque
chose de voilà qui serait moins
perturbant parce que j'ai l'impression
que l'enfant même si vous dites qu'il
n'est pas du tout perturbé ben peut-être
qu'il est quand même perturbé parce que
c'est quand même impressionnant
intrigant et peut-être qu'ils oublient
ce que vous dites et il ne fait que vous
regardez c'est exactement ça de julien
jeudi qu'en fait tout le monde est
perturbée que ce soit les enfants ou les
adultes ou les grands parents qu'ils
arrivent la première fois les simples
pendant 10 minutes
ouais c'est justement ils ne disent rien
il soit rejoué c'est lourd mais qu'est
ce que vous en savez que ça dure que dix
minutes en fait le minutes mais alors
deux minutes qu'est ce que ça fait deux
trois ans que ça m'arrive régulièrement
je vois bien mais je vois aussi avec
vous au bout de 2 minutes vous commencez
à oublier mon apparence et ou bien
entendu uniquement comme un outil
l'imaginaire comme ça allez rennes mais
je suis artisan électricien section de
maternelle il commence en septembre ils
ne savaient déjà pas qu'ils vont revenir
après midi ils ne savent penser qu'ils
vont revenir le lendemain certains n'ont
même pas vu d'autres personnes que leurs
parents ils n'ont même pas vu d'autres
enfants donc effectivement ils n'ont pas
besoin d'avoir quelqu'un qui est ma tête
en tout cas au tout début septembre jean
michel vous dites ah bah non parce que
moi j'ai horreur professeurs comme ça
qui est très basse et je ne suis
d'accord avec géraldine ses trajets
j'adore les tatouages mais moi j'aurai à
nos preuves comme ça j'aurais fait pipi
au lit j'aurais fait des cauchemars la
nuit ça c'est sûr bien sûr mais là il
dit et en plus quand un professeur est
obligé de sévir parfois donc là quand
vous êtes gentil tout va bien mais quand
vous énervez voilà moi je me bats au
courant tout de suite ça fait peur pas
besoin de m'énerver il sut que je vais
regarder ça suffit alors pardonnez moi
moi il ya un détail qui me choque
particulièrement celle intérieure des
yeux et tatoué août que je trouve quand
même que c'est très dangereux parce que
c'est les métaux lourds mais ça ça vous
regarde
oui nous est très beau mais donc je
pense que franchement tout passe
beaucoup de choses passent par le regard
est votre regard je le trouve dénaturer
donc je trouve que ça pose un vrai
problème sur le long terme par bonne et
moi c'est aussi ce que pense meilleurs
archers oui ah oui qu'est-ce qu'il vous
dise votre hiérarchie d'ailleurs c'est
vous arrivez n'omettant vous arrivez
mine lorsque vous êtes professeur
remplaçant ils vous ont lieu quand ils
vous voient arriver ils vous disposez
les directeurs d'école alors déjà dans
le primaire les directeurs ne sont pas
les supérieurs à nos collègues donc la
hiérarchie c'est l'inspectrice d'accord
il ya effectivement elle est du même
avis que madame morini bosc
elle considère qu'il ya un côté inhumain
à ça et c'est pour ça qu'elle ne veut
plus que j'enseignais maternelle ah oui
parce qu'elle a elle ne veut plus en
fait faut recevoir de lettre de plainte
et elle veut juste que ce que tout se
passe bien qu'il me laisse uniquement en
élémentaire afin de prévenir
d'éventuelles plaintes
c'est un monsieur c'est incroyable parce
que c'est vrai que l'on se pose tous la
question mais dans la tous ceux qui nous
regardent se dit est-ce que j'aurais
laissé mon enfant aller à l'école avec
avec sylvain je vous dis oui je suis
assez étonné avec grand plaisir
oui la terre parce que dire non pour moi
c'est de la discrimination oui
alors j'ai tenté d'obtenir de la part
des services de l'éducation nationale de
l'essonne tente à palaiseau cas est vrai
une explication parce que dans ces cas
là quand on vire quelqu'un pour ça pour
un tatouage c'est à l'employeur de
prouver que sa cause problème tant que
ce n'est pas prouvé c'est de la
discrimination et vous pourriez gagner
au tribunal donc moi je dis oui bien sûr
il ya aucune raison de dire non et je
trouve que moi ma fille mélanie ciel
vous avez j'en suis très fier alors
j'espère que vous lui enseigne aurait un
jour alors silva qu'est ce qu'ils disent
et aux professeurs à ce que vous
entendez bien que ce professeur il voit
et ce qu'ils disent oui ils disent rien
il veut juste faire leur travail en fait
ils veulent qu'on les laisse travailler
tranquille et ça c'est déjà mal passés
avec un élève qui vous a dit quelque
chose qui vous dénoncez les critiques
que j'ai moi ne sont jamais directes
c'est soit charme avec qui vous allez
voter car on a peur de vous mais les
élèves il dit ce qu'il pense que ce soit
gentil ou méchant donc c'est ils vont le
sortir comme ça mais ça ne veut pas dire
que ça va rester et vous leur dites quoi
vous ouais ça sur votre parcours vous
arrivez charles rozoy soir c'est moi
qu'on vous présentait déjà moi ça fait
12 ans que je suis sur la même
circonscription donc à palaiseau et
villebon ceux qui connaissent donc j'ai
soit eu les grands frères soient les
grandes soeurs soit ils m'ont vu par mon
activité artistique à la télévision au
cinéma ou oui les yeux ces nouveaux
quand même dans votre démarche c'est un
an et demi oui c'est vrai même nouveau
et donc ils vous disent quoi qu'est ce
que tu as fait pourquoi t'as fait ça on
va peut-être qui vous voit d'ailleurs du
ce2 oui non non elles et ils vous disent
quoi mais rien parce que ça fait partie
d'un tout en fait ils enfin curial et
non sens allait surprendre deux minutes
et puis alain bernard en chef de m au
niveau enfants vous oui basse mais ce
qui est important souligné quand même
c'est que au delà de l'apparence on n'a
jamais remis en question ses qualités
professionnelles et ça c'est quand même
l'essentiel est ailleurs c'est un bon
prof symbole enseignants donc c'est vrai
que c'est pas évident comme il est
magnifique
moi c'est les yeux qui me font peur
c'est bon
le rsa va rester on voulait tous et
partout partout oui je suis entièrement
recouverts ouais partout rené malleville
c'est oui ou c'est non la petite
pancarte a cédé quelques heures après
c'est générationnel
il ya des personnes avec toi est-ce que
tu la laisses que ses petits enfants
je t'explique bas mais plutôt bien passé
mais les enfants quittent l occupant
mais je veux dire c'est générationnel
mais qu'au moins 60 des 13 ans [ __ ] tu
djezzy tu es d'accord méthane des jeunes
pour peut-être que il serait d'accord tu
aspires générationnel moi je sais que
nombre n'a jamais nommé
je te dis fonctions et jerry zucker mai
j'amènerai pas mais en vain à ton école
là toi quoi je dirais peut-être que je
fais vieux je pensais mais je m'en fous
c'est je dis ce que je pense
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi rené saleh
font pas parce que moi d'abord c'est
comment de tous en nature connaît jamais
connu déjà cause c'est comment on
regarde si tu me dis le pétard voilà
mais moi j'ai jamais si même pétards
jets ça tu étais jamais fumé un pétard
qu'est ce que vous diriez à rené sylvain
pour le convaincre par exemple si vous
dis non je veux pas mettre mais après
dans l'est les gens n'ont pas le choix
en fait c'est à dire que c'est en france
ça marche par la carte scolaire donc on
met ses enfants à l'école qu'à côté de
chez soi fois sauf si on veut payer pour
révéler les canadiens est ce que vous
avez déjà une conversion par exemple est
qu un avec un parent qu'est ce que vous
diriez à rené pour le combat que vous
lui direz je n'ai jamais eu une
conversation parce que jamais personne
ne vient me faire de critiques en face à
ben si jamais ça arrive et je pense que
juste le simple fait de leur parler ça
suffirait pas ce que ce que selon lui
victime c'est une forme de xénophobie
c'est à dire littéralement la peur de
l'inconnu la peur de l'étranger ils ne
me connaissent pas don qu'ils imaginent
les pires choses alors que s'il venait
simplement de parler même de ce qu'ils
ont mangé à midi ou de l'ip temps qu'il
fait ou que sais-je
bref ça se passera tout de suite mieux
benjamin castanet est ce que vous
comprenez que certains parents soient
fois inquiet bien entendu oui aucune
tribu réfection les battre mais est ce
qu'il est les enfants nous posent des
questions mais pourquoi pas fait ça
pourquoi des glaces et ça parce que
forcément un enfant c'est super curieux
il va vous dire beaucoup d'aléas tintin
regard comme ça on dirait en un avatar
il faut bien expliquer quelque chose je
le sais je réponds avec plaisir aux
questions et pas en classe en classe je
suis professeur une récréation aucun
problème alors il ya il ya quelques
jours
mine de rien il ya une les enfants d'une
maman qui aurait eu peur de l'apparence
de sylvain elle témoigné dans le
parisien elle dit il n'était pas dans la
classe de sept de cet instit
mais ils m'ont dit c'est bizarre c'est
effrayant il fait peur il me parlait
plus de son look de leur propre
maîtresse j'ai moi même été impressionné
en le voyant c'est une mère d'élève qui
a parlé dans le parisien je trouve cela
inapproprié a dit pour des cp ou déçus
eux c'est comme s'ils s'étaient déguisés
pour halloween
je suis très surprise que l'éducation
nationale laisse faire ça il y a dix ont
refusé l'entrée aux élèves qui
arrivaient à l'école avec les cheveux
bleus si c'est un bon professeur ena qui
dit aussi cela ne change rien pour moi
mais il y en a beaucoup que ça divise
parce que surtout aujourd'hui les tenues
à l'école saint john
voilà on les voit biais des fois des
jeans troués des trucs qu'on dit non tu
retourne chez toi vous qu'est ce qu'est
ce que vous répondez vous aux maires qui
disent mine de rien c'est un exemple 57
ans est pas un exemple pascal et on vous
dit vous n'êtes pas un exemple pour les
autres élèves à je suis un exemple par
mon la façon dont je m'exprime par ma
pédagogie et puis par mon attitude et
c'est ce qui est le plus important après
ma tenue je suis propre jeu bien sûr
douce par jour je n'ai jamais ça ornée
suivre donc
il ya d'autres façons d'être modélisant
que par son aspect et après si on
commence à discriminer au niveau des
tatouages on va faire pareil avec la
couleur de peau avec le handicap avec
plein d'autres facteurs jean-mi vouliez
dire par là handicapant le subit on jase
il ya quelque chose qu'on s'impose
mais c'est au final c'est le même
résultat la même chose face et martine
aubry joli poème pardon
c'est vraiment un débat essentiel sur le
droit à la différence à être soi même si
on sait que je soutiens totalement le
taux n'a le droit d'être différent sinon
on va juger alors oui vous n'êtes pas
beau et puis un autre on va dire oui lui
il est trop petit trop grand ça va aller
la raison de ce qu'il ne dit pas des
gros noms qui font toujours les faibles
et s'était empressé à partie quand il ya
des enfants qui ont perdu devrait
s'assoupir les minorités y est c'est
parce qu'on en a discuté maintenant ils
ont trop peur de lui en parler elle a
peut-être peur car la peur par la sim
tracé moi ce principe aussi jura et même
et surtout que sylvain vos yeux c'est
quand même un risque
il me l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que c'est presque une
automutilation vous risquez d'être un
aveugle ce n'est pas une automutilation
mais c'était la version allemande et n'a
que 10 ans l'équipe qui n'a que 10 ans
d'existence à vos prêtres donc on n'a
aucun recul garder chez eux leur est
membre était interdite en france et
ailleurs en france est exactement et
valérie qui je disais justement et je
connais un petit peu gilles là dessus
c'est une façon aussi parce que la dame
disait ils l'ont vu et ils ont eu peur
on était une façon justement de dépasser
simplement la première impression
la différence c'est aussi dépassé la
première impression on a peur de quoi de
l'autre quand on a peur de l'autre c'est
parce qu'on ne le connaît pas donc il
faut c'est aussi une façon d'apprendre
aux enfants à dépasser la peur de
l'autre
c'est à dire la peur de l'inconnu et
d'aller vers cette inconnue pour ensuite
lui dire je ne je ne tombe regard fatah
personne ne ressemble pas à ma personne
mais justement nous prouve moi que j'ai
pas avoir peur de toi et c'est ça aussi
que par l'apprentissage c'est ça aussi
qui va aussi loin
est ce que vous êtes triste quand on
vous dit que vous ne pouvez pas
enseigner jeu pour moi non parce que
c'est mon maternelle à sedan on
m'interdit on met carte des maternelles
mais finalement je me retrouve un peu ce
que j'aimais pas trop les petits de ce
sont donc j'aimerais bien faire
parce que oui mais si un jour le
rectorat 6 puis le principe je le trouve
ce que vous direz sans vous concerter 10
est complètement d'enseignés parce que
c'est pour ça je pense ça me ferait mal
parce que c'est quand même une vocation
on ne peut pas être enseignant de nos
jours si on nie si on n'y croit pas
vraiment moi je veux être en scène
depuis que j'ai 10 ans donc ça fait 25
ans maintenant que je songe à faire ce
métier là alors il paraît que lors de
votre première mise au placard
ils vont maintenant nous avons besoin
des véhicules vous allez avec une vous
voulez vous faire faire autre chose ils
vous ont dit on va vous mettre dans les
bureaux c'est ça quand j'ai ouï alors
l'année dernière c'est ça ils m'ont ils
m'ont laissé de côté pendant deux mois
donc j'étais j'attendais entre deux
classes cela ne faisait rien et quand je
suis un entretien effectivement auprès
de la hiérarchie
je suis quasiment sûr qu'ils allaient me
proposait un une voie de garage d'un
administratif
ils ne me l'ont pas dit mais je les ai
sentis oui d'un côté on me tend il ya un
côté provocation ou sa liche et
mistinguett très bien en faisant ce
métier là qu avec ce look ça poserait
problème
pas du tout bassila j'ai une question à
vous poser mine de rien sylvain vous
avez eu des problèmes yahia est
cependant beaucoup de temps pourquoi
avoir rajouté les yeux c'est ça qui me
dit parce que oui voilà c'est 11e' vous
rajoute vous rajouter en plus les yeux
c'est ouais c'est ça le truc mais je ne
me suis jamais posé de questions quand
on regarde les autres moi je suis
passionné de tatouage d'accord à bout
d'un moment c'est le tatouage c'est
comme l'amour c'est dire que quand on
est amoureux de quelqu'un on y pense
tout le temps matin midi et soir
et là j'avais ce besoin de le faire
restait la dernière zone et donc j'ai
c'était c'est vraiment très égoïste pour
moi c'est ma passion jamais je n'ai
pensé à mon travail c'est fun naïvement
j'ai pensé que ce serait accepter en
2020 en france à battre est bien bas en
tout cas vous avez eu ici vous êtes
activement à voir ce qu'en pensent
certains expectat heures tiens c'est
intéressant ce tatouage voyous passerait
très 49,5
je crois que sylvain qui était venu déjà
dans une de mes démission c'est un type
exceptionnel mais voilà comme ça mais
c'est un enseignant exceptionnel n'a
jamais eu aucun problème avec un élève
ou sur ces techniques d'enseignement
donc voilà c'est une vraie vraie
question en tout cas merci sylvain
d'abord
[Applaudissements]